In Souls we talk a lot about disparity
about what lies between light and dark
life and death, heat and cold and today
we discuss two different absolutes.
We discuss what lies between those with
power and those without.
And in this case,
what lies between them is a wall.
A stone wall that appeared quite suddenly
cementing this divide between hollows
and the nobles who control them
and mind you
wall or not there has always been a
divide. In the days of Lordran humanity
was a rising force and as a result they
were feared imprisoned and shepherded
they were taught to fear the undead
rising in their ranks.
In Drangleic the
undead were subjugated once more
of course, but they were also
experimented upon and all the while they
were expected to sacrifice themselves as
Gwyn once did, to keep those Royals in power.
And now in Lothric the unkindled
born of the ash of these unending
sacrifices, journeys through a small town
of suffering undead.
It was here where a
thief once fancied himself a martyr for
the poor.
It was the state of this town that drove
Greirat to climb the wall
[Greirat]
"Greirat the thief was a some well-known name...
Until I ended up rotting in a cell..."
[Vaati]
the head covering he wears was once used to cover
the heads of the lesser folk people who
were said to work as slaves throughout
Lothric but occasionally it was used to
shame and humiliate criminals.
We have reason to believe that Greirat was
indeed a slave to the kingdom, once
for he knows the castle grounds well.
But here in lower Lothric, Greirat is caught and
imprisoned for the very first time.
[Greirat]
"Ah, you are no jailer, are you?"
"No. No, you are from far away."
"Judging by the bell, you must be some of
"that Unkindled Ash."
"Remarkable"
"If that's true, then I have a favor to ask."
"Below the high wall is a musty
"little town, not the home of any Lord"
"just a very old settlement of Undead."
"An old woman Loretta lives there."
"Please, give her this ring?"
"I-I'm not asking for charity, in f-in fact,
"if you do this for me I'll be sure to
"repay you in kind and I may be a petty
"thief but I've got more wits that most royalty."
"What do you say then, hmm?"
"Very well."
"I humbly place my faith in you. I am Greirat,
"of the Undead Settlement, and I
"promise to assist you."
"Give this ring to
"Loretta at the base of the highwall."
"Do your part and I'll do mine."
[Vaati]
We can't know who Loretta was. We don't
know why her corpse clutches a bone nor
do we know what Greirat's relationship to
her was, the one detail we do know is
that the little rare ring he gives us to
give to her is a tear stone, which has
the uncanny ability to sense imminent
death protecting its wearer in their
final moments, so whoever she was to him
it seems he cared for her and sensed her
death was close.
[Greirat]
"Heavens! she was already dead?"
"Thank you."
"I'm not surprised though..."
"Almost relieved, really."
"You can keep the ring."
"As..."
"Well..."
"A little trinket of thanks I suppose."
[Vaati]
He breaks his composure when you appear
back and from then on dedicates himself
fully to your cause.
[Greirat]
"Ah, there you are."
"I was thinking..."
"You know I'm a petty thief,
"well, perhaps I'll go on the prowl."
"Everyone's dead or hollowed away anyway,
"right? So i might as well fetch some
"weapons or treasure for you."
"Well, what do you think?"
"Thank you. You will not be disappointed.
"I will leave for some time."
"So long for now."
"Do stay safe, you hear?"
"Or my efforts will have been for naught."
[Vaati]
Don't take Greirat's robbery of the
undead settlement lightly, it was his
home. It was the poor there who inspired
him to climb the wall and risked his
life and it was the settlement where he
cared deeply for someone. His thievery of
the settlement is kind of an admission
that everyone there, no longer matters to him
you do
and so emboldened by his
new purpose he asks to put himself in
harm's way once again
(Greirat) "oh hello fine work i'd say
discovering Irithyll in the Boreal Valley all in a
day's work
if the tales are true it is
home to old moon-worshipping nobles
and should be packed with treasure
what do you think?"
"Shall I go and see what i can find?"
"mmmm a fine choice
i am Greirat the thief, what I bring back will be
worthy of that name"
(Vaati) that name is also
known by others
(Patches) "Ahh, I see you've met Greirat.
The slinking rodent. but he did me a good
turn back in Lothric dungeon
Doubtless I should do something about that little
debt...
well maybe not, well probably believe
he's still standing"
(Vaati) this is Patches, the hyena, the spider, the unbreakable
by now we have a pretty good grasp of his
character and it's the same character
who for the first time expresses a
genuine concern about the well-being of
another
(Patches) "hey what happened to Greirat anyhow?
I haven't seen him at all lately
if you know where he's scurried off to
be sure and tell me
I need to stock up, and if he's gone and croaked
he'll have left a goldmine.
right yes
I see how it is.. some things can't be divulged
even between friends
that comes with the territory
fine but if you happen to recall any
details, do be a saint, do it for old
Patches Boutique of Wonders at least.. Aye?"
(Vaati) if Patches is still alive to tell you this
then it means you've forgiven him for a
great deal of things you've forgiven him
for impersonating The Onion Knight, for
locking you in a tower; he's tried to
kill you twice now probably and it's
understandable right that you wouldn't
want to tell him where your friend is
gone
however Greirat can be saved by the
very thief you tried to protect him from...
(Patches) "well happen to recall anything important?
About where that old rat scurried off to.
What? Gone all the way to Irithyll, has he?
Well, there can't be much left of that frozen sprawl
The old rat, he's gone off the deep end this time..."
(Vaati) was Greirat truly saved by Sigward here?
it's possible or rather was he saved by an
impersonator who was protecting their
reputation
(Greirat) "now that we're both safe and sound
thank the Gods for that
I don't like cutting things so close.
i might have died if it
wasn't for that peculiar Onion Knight
but in the end it all paid off
take a good look, that's sure to be of
some use
you know I was thinking about leaving
for another round of thieving there must
be something of use in Lothric castle
I'm aware of the danger, that castle is a
deathtrap
not a single man has returned from the
castle unscathed, even back in the day...
but I don't want to sit around and die a petty rat
and I consider myself your friend"
(Patches) "off to Lothric
the Castle of no return
That old thief's lost it if he thinks he has a chance in there
It's not like he's new to this game
whats gotten in to him?"
(Vaati) his debt repaid even Patches wouldn't
risk Lothric for a friend...
but Greirat well...he risks it for us
self sacrifice it's in his character after all...
but i don't think we're the only
reason he goes
think back to when he hid
his grief over Loretta to how is so
absorbed that he doesn't even notice you
immediately after this dives into danger
on your behalf his sorrow apparently
forgotten and you think that's strange I
don't think his sorrow is forgotten at all
(Greirat) "I lived a petty rat, but would rather not
die as one..."
Greirat the thief
a petty rat
looking for an honorable escape
Thank you Vaati for letting us add English subtitles. We had a blast! :)